[Music]
welcome back to harvard unboxed
it's hard to believe it's been almost
nine months now since nvidia unveiled
its first ampere-based product the
geforce rtx 3080
though i suppose it might have also felt
like an eternity for those of you who've
been trying to get one
for the past nine months or so the rtx
3080 was a hugely exciting product when
it was first released back in september
of last year
it offered 20 greater performance on
average over the rtx 2080 ti
with a suggested retail price that was
around 40 lower
the only issue of course being the fact
that you couldn't really buy it
as it sold out in seconds and then
tracking one down at the msrp a few
months after release was extremely
difficult
and really verged on impossible now nine
months later it's still
virtually impossible to get your hands
on an rtx 3080 with all retailers still
out of stock
and of course it's absolutely impossible
to get one anywhere near the msrp
as cards are regularly selling on ebay
for over
two thousand dollars us since the
release of the 3080 nvidia's also spat
out a fully unlocked version of the
ga102 silicon
called the rtx 3090 and it costs
a cool 1500 us basically
it made no sense whatsoever and i said
as much in my day one review last year
after that we got the rtx 3070 which was
based on the smaller ga 104 die
and at almost 40 percent smaller it's
possible for nvidia to get many more of
these dyes
out of a single wafer and it would seem
as a result supply has been
slightly better but ultimately still
quite terrible
also sharing the ga 104 die is the rtx
3060 ti
probably the hardest to find of all the
ampere-based gpus
and that's because nvidia has been
prioritized in the higher margin 3070
and with seemingly strong yields there's
been little need or incentive to produce
the lower margin 3060 ti
then most recently received the geforce
rtx 3060 based on the 300 millimeter
squared geo 106 die
and it's meant to cost 330 us but of
course you can't buy it and you
certainly can't get one for anywhere
near the msrp
so here we are gamers still can't buy a
graphics card in mid 2021 or at least
not easily and
pricing is still sky high ideally we'd
like to see amd and nvidia release sub
us products which would help to ease the
supply of shoes and give gamers a better
chance of buying a graphics card
at a more reasonable price but rather
than do any of that
nvidia's refreshing ga 102 with the
geforce rtx
3080 ti yup another super expensive gpu
just nine months after releasing the
first set of
super expensive gpus that you still
can't buy
so why are they doing this well in short
to make more money
at least that's my take now if you don't
believe in videos selling gpus directly
to miners which happens to be our
opinion
we believe it's the aibs and or
distributors who are selling to miners
in large volumes
so if that's the case nvidia is missing
out on a lot of money here
of course they're still doing very well
out of the rtx 3090 sales
but letting go slightly defective geo
102 silicon for less than half of the
price
probably stings quite a bit right now so
rather than do that they've segmented
further with the rtx 3080 ti
allowing them to maximize profits of
silicon that's not quite good enough to
be an rtx 3090
meaning rather than sell a good portion
of the defective silicon as a 700
product they can now extend the profit
margin by roughly 70 percent
this all means that the rtx 3080 ti
exists purely
to make more money shocker i know and in
an effort to convince you that it's
worth more than the rtx 3080
the 38 you can't buy right now anyway
they're throwing in an extra 2 gigabytes
of vram
couple that with an 18 increase in cores
and the wider 384
bit memory bus and you basically have an
rtx 3090 with half the vram
we're talking about just two and a half
percent fewer cores than the 3090.
even at 4k the rtx 3090 is just 13
faster than the 3080 on average so you
can expect the 3080 ti to be very
similar to the 3090 in terms of
performance
and likely only around 10 faster than
the 3080.
that makes the 3080 ti about as
pointless as the 3090
given that at msrp it should cost little
over 70
more than the 3080 for maybe 10 more
performance
so well beyond the point of diminishing
returns
that's probably not a great way to start
this review but there's really no
mystery here
sometimes with these refreshers we get
an odd mix of core and memory
configurations
but that's not the case this time the
3080ti has basically the same memory
subsystem as the 3090
with a few less cores with that said
let's go over a few benchmarks using the
foundation model and please note all
benchmark results are based on amd and
nvidia gpus running at the official
specifications
so no factory overclocking in total i've
tested 12 games at 1080p
1440p and 4k but we're only going to
look
at the data for a few of the titles
while the rest will be made available to
our floatplane and petro members
but of course the all-important dozen
game average data will be included in
this video
we've also got some power overclocking
and ray tracing data to go over as well
it's also worth noting that all of this
data is fresh and this is the first time
it's being made available
after weeks upon weeks of testing we now
have all of our data up to date on the
new ryzen 9 5950x test system
which has been configured with 32
gigabytes of dual rank dual channel ddr4
3200 cell 14 memory
okay let's get into the results first up
we've got the death stranding results at
1080p
and here the 3082i delivered 3090 light
performance
we're talking a one to two fps margin
here and that meant the 38 dti was just
four percent faster than the 3080
but quite a bit slower than the 6800 xt
and 6900 xt
increasing the resolution of 1440p
allowed the 3082 item matched the 6800
xt
while it was again delivering 3090 light
performance
this also saw it beat the 3080 by a 9
margin
so not far off the 10 margin i was
expecting to see
then finally at 4k the 3082 i matched
the 3090 exactly with 121 fps on average
making it just two and a half percent
slower than the 1600 xt
it was also 13 faster than the rtx 3080
so again basically what we were
expecting to see
moving on to the watchdogs legion
results we find more of the same
that is to say that the rtx 3080 ti is
basically an rtx 3090
with half the vram the 3082i did slip
behind the 3090 at 1440p
though here it was still only five
percent slower but still 12 percent
faster than the rtx 3080
so again basically we'd expect a product
of this configuration to sit
then at 4k the 380ti was just three
percent slow on the rtx 3090
and 13 faster than the 3080 making it
just five percent faster than the radeon
rx 6900 xt
of course in a normal market if you
cared about value you'd get either the
6800 xt
or rtx 3080 next up we have assassin's
creed valhalla here we're looking at 96
fps on average at 1080p
using the maximum in-game quality
settings this meant that the 38dti was
just four percent slower than the 3090
and just three percent faster than the
3080.
then at 1440p it's slotted in right
between the 3080 and 3090 with 82fps on
average
it's also worth noting that while
watchdog's legion isn't an nvidia
sponsored title
assassin's creed valhalla is an amd
that said the radeon gpus do have a
massive performance advantage here
the 1600xt for example was a massive 28
faster than the 3080ti then moving to 4k
sees the rtx 380 ti average 59 fps
allowing it to match the rtx 3090 and
6800 xt
though it was still 11 slower than the
6900 xt
moreover when compared to the rtx 3080
we're looking at a mere 7
performance increase the last game we're
going to bother looking at is
cyberpunk 2077 and at 1080p we're
looking at comparable performance
between the 3080 ti 3090 and 6900 xt
this meant that the 3080ti was just 10
faster than the original 3080.
then at 1440p the new 3082i is just 8
percent faster than the vanilla
3080 and five percent slower than the 30
90 and we're also looking at comparable
performance with the radeon rx 6900 xt
finally at 4k the 38dti was just four
percent slower than 3090 and 11
faster than the 3080 and then six
percent faster than the 1600 xt
so similar margins to what we've seen in
the previous three titles so let's stop
looking at the game benchmarks and just
jump to the 12 game average
okay so at 1080p across the 12 games
tested the geforce rtx 3080ti
is and wait for it basically an rtx 3090
with half the vram
we're talking about two percent slower
on average and just six percent faster
than the rtx 3080
and for those of you seeking maximum
performance for low resolution
competitive gaming
the 6900 xt is slightly faster offering
seven percent more performance on
average
now at 1440p the margins do grow a
little bit here the 38dti was four
percent slower than the 3090.
that said it's now only five percent
slower than the 6900 xt
so overall for rasterization performance
the radeon gpu was a little bit faster
than a dozen game sample
while offering even more vram finally at
4k
the 3080ti is able to beat the 600xt
albeit though by just a three percent
margin
it was again just four percent slower
than the rtx 3090 and just nine percent
faster than the rtx 3080.
now for a look at power consumption and
for this review i'm going to focus on
the total system results and put the
nvidia pcat testing on hold
i'd like to further investigate power
consumption soon as a few of you have
pointed out that nvidia is technically
cheating here but offloading most of the
scheduling work to the cpu
which increases cpu consumption and
lowers gpu consumption
therefore measuring the total system
provides a much more accurate picture of
power usage
so here's a look at power consumption in
doom and as you can see the rtx 380 ti
is very similar to the 3080 and 3090
again slotting in between the two
in this example the 3080 ti was on
average six percent faster than the 600
xt and doom
but push total system usage nine percent
higher so rd and a2
is slightly more efficient though
overall it's going to make a very little
difference to gamers
the margin would no doubt increase in
amd's favor if we isolated the cpu and
gpu power usage and that's something
that we might start to do in the future
okay so here's a quick look at some ray
tracing results and we'll start with
metro exodus enhanced
all testing has been conducted at 1440p
and even without the aid of dlss we're
seeing some pretty impressive frame
rates here
the rtx 3080 ti was good for 90 fps on
average using the highest quality
in-game settings
though do note that variable rate
shading was set to 4 times
anyway because the rtx 3082i is
basically an rtx 3090
the ray tracing performance is also
basically the same
that means titles that were designed
with nvidia's ray tracing implementation
in mind will perform pretty horribly on
radeon gpus
and that's what we're seeing here with
the 1600 xt which was 28
slower for normal ray tracing and 38
slow off ultra
and of course the geforce gpus are much
faster again with dlss enabled
resident evil village works much better
with radeon gpus and as a result the
1600 xt
is a lot more competitive here and
despite still trailing the 380ti by 18
margin performance overall was still
very impressive
of course when discussing the 3080ti
results they're again best summed up by
saying
it's basically an rtx 3090 lastly we
have watchdogs legion and again this is
an nvidia sponsored title that's
optimized to work with nvidia's ray
tracing implementation as a result the
6900xt fares quite poorly and the 38dti
again mimics 3090 light performance
before wrapping up the testing i do have
a few aib cards on hand so we'll look at
those and then do some very quick
overclocking now nvidia's own founders
edition model appears to have just
borrowed the cooler from the rtx 3080 as
they appear physically identical
however whereas the rtx 3080 featured a
total board power rating of 320 watts
the 3080ti jumps up to 350 watts so a 9
increase this increased power saw the
peak operating temperature rise by 2
degrees to 77 degrees
and the fan speed increased by 200 rpm
to 2100 rpm
so as far as the end user experience is
concerned they're basically the same
under these conditions the fe model
averaged a core clock speed of 1770
megahertz which is well above the
advertised gpu boost clock
but of course that's how nvidia's gpu
boost works anyway it's quite an
impressive result for a dual slot
graphics card so bear that in mind as we
take a look at the much bigger
aib models we'll start with the asus rtx
3080 ti tough gaming this is basically
just a copy and paste of the original
3080 tough gaming
and i've got to say that's not a bad
thing as that model was excellent
as i discovered in a detailed review
last year this new 3080ti version works
remarkably well
peaking at just 64 degrees in our stress
test with a fan speed of 2000 rpm
and here it averaged a core clock speed
of 1830 megahertz
asus also sent over the new rog strix lc
rtx 3080 ti oc
and this is another highly impressive
graphics card
last year i checked out the rog strix lc
version of the 6800xt which worked very
well
and my only real criticism was the mess
of cables that ran
from the radiator to the graphics card
thankfully though asus took note and has
now slaved all of those cables with the
liquid cooling tubes for a much
neater package out of the box this model
peaked at just 49 degrees with a fan
speed of just 1500 rpm
and that allowed for an average clock
speed of 1920 megahertz so a 5
increase over the tough gaming model
while running 15 degrees cooler
and even quieter of course this premium
model will be much more expensive
but that's just par for the course when
discussing these liquid cooled graphics
cards
then finally also on hand is the new msi
rtx 38 eti supreme x
a gigantic air cooled graphics card to
give you an idea of just how big and
heavy this thing is
the foundation model weighs 365 grams
and the tough gaming 1400 grams the
supremax though
it comes in at grams measuring 332
millimeters long
140 millimeters tall and 60 millimeters
wide
it's a beast but despite the massive
dimensions
the results are less than impressive as
the card picked at 78 degrees saw a
whopping 14 degrees hotter than the
tough gaming
though it was a bit quieter as the fans
spun at just 1600 rpm
still if noise normalized i don't expect
it will be able to beat the tough gaming
the calls also clocked at 1875 megahertz
which is just a two and a half percent
increase over the tough gaming
overall not a bad result it's just not
particularly impressive given the weight
and dimensions
now here's a look at how they performed
in shut off the tomb raider at 1440p
both stock and overclocked i was only
able to squeeze four percent more out of
the foundation model
hitting 1885 megahertz on the cause with
the memory at 21 gigabits per second
the tough gaming was a mere one percent
faster out of the box and i was only
able to squeeze a further three percent
from
it hitting 178 fps on average with a
core frequency of 1900 megahertz
the liquid cooled asus rog strix lc was
the most impressive managing 178 fps out
of the box
and with the 1980 megahertz overclock
went up to 192 fps
so that's an additional 8 performance
making it 13
faster than a stock rtx 3080 ti not
exactly amazing stuff but
that's gpu overclocking these days the
supreme x was also able to match the rog
strix lc out of the box
though it did fall short when
overclocked but this will come down to
silicon quality so don't read too much
into the overclocking results here
they're an extremely rough guide at best
so there you have it the new geforce rtx
3080 ti
as i've already said a number of times
now it's basically an rtx 39 with half
the vram
and while it is meant to be cheaper with
an msrp of 1200
us you can expect to pay rtx 3090
pricing
so thousands upon thousands of dollars
it's basically just a way for nvidia to
sell silicon that couldn't be binned for
use in a 30 90
at a higher price normally this sort of
thing wouldn't be an issue
in fact a refresh like this is kind of
expected but the reason this refresh is
an issue
is due to the fact that nvidia hasn't
finished releasing ampere
i mean where are the affordable sub 200
us models or even the sub 300
us models so come on nvidia read the
room
there's just no way this release is
going to sit well with gamers
and after all the talk about trying to
help gamers with hardware limiters for
mining
they then turn around and release the
rtx 3080 ti it's just so damn tone-deaf
i'm really not sure what else to say
about this release the rtx 3080ti
is impressively fast it is technically
an excellent product
and the extra 2 gigabytes of vram is
very welcomed
but at 1200 u.s and with the current
stock
issues it's just a poorly timed release
that
frankly makes no sense at least from a
gamer's perspective
now you might have noticed that i've
skipped over our usual cost per frame
graph
obviously with pricing the way it is
comparing the value of these products is
rather pointless
and i see little sense in using these
scalper prices as
they're a bit all over the place and an
average of what you're seeing online
almost certainly won't be representative
of what you'll be seeing and say a week
from now
so in short as i've already said
multiple times now like the geforce rtx
39 to your radeon rx 1600xt
in a normal market the 3080ti makes no
sense
and in terms of cost per frame you'd be
far better off buying the rtx 3080
or if you really care about vram
capacity the 6800 xt
anyway i've really got nothing else to
say on this one apart from the fact that
it looks like nvidia
we're a bit blown out of the water at
computex this year by amd's announcement
of fsr or fidelity fx super resolution
which we'll be analyzing shortly or tim
will be analyzing that for us shortly
but the fact that amd is claiming to be
improving the performance of older
geforce gpus
and potentially killing off dlss in the
process well that's just a horrific blow
to nvidia
and it came just ahead of this 1200 us
money grab
yikes of course amd still has a lot to
prove with fsr in terms of image quality
and game support
but the announcement was impressive and
certainly something that's being
celebrated by gamers
i'm not sure we can say the same thing
about the 1200 rtx 3080 ti
if you enjoyed the video give it one of
those please subscribe for more content
we will have the
rtx 3070 ti review shortly on the
channel
uh of course we will be analyzing stuff
like fsr
and just plenty more gpu related content
as well as all the usual stuff we do
here at harvard unboxed also if you'd
like to support the channel directly
floatplane patreon links for those are
in the video description that will get
you access to monthly live streams that
to myself where we discuss stuff just
like this in a bit more detail or
a bit more personally uh behind the
scenes content
q a's an awesome discord server great
community over there so if you're
interested in joining that again links
are in the video description check it
out if not
perfectly fine and i would like to just
thank you for watching this video i'm
your host steve and i'll see
you again next time
[Music]
you